we could use another bath for mother
nature we still have a chance for some
thunderstorms this afternoon and today
and this evening but it's a small chance
not a huge chance as we look out from
black mountain which is where the big
thunderstorms were erupting yesterday
and picked up about a third of an inch
of rain off across the valley looking
pretty clear this morning a little hazy
not much in the way of winds 80s across
town still 90 downtown 84 on the strip
and 81 at seven hills with 84 in nellis
85 centennial hills big thunderstorms in
the spring mountains last night as well
and sharing his shot this is from kevin
royal thank you so much from henderson
seeing the big shafts of rain coming
down in the southeast yesterday
afternoon great picture you can always
share your photos with us pix at eight
newsnow dot com we appreciate them
officially we did pick up some rain at
the airport 17 hundredths of an inch
which is actually a record for
yesterday's date puts us at about a
third of an inch for the year we're
still almost two inches behind so we
need some more rainfall but boy this
area of town right here in the southeast
is where we picked up the nice rainfall
and the rest of the valley nothing as
far as any measurable rainfall probably
not even sprinkles or drops it was
really right over the southeast corner
and then huge thunderstorms over two
inches of rain up there in the spring
mountains and rainbow canyon had
flooding it was pretty bad it was flood
warnings until 10 o'clock last night
radar is clear this morning but boy
yesterday afternoon we had all that
moisture get cooked up and you could see
we did have another little cell out
there on the far west side too that did
get a little bit of rain but just a lot
of neighborhoods just missing out spring
mountains again getting clobbered so
we'll see where the thunderstorms pop up
probably over the mountains will be the
best opportunity high pressure will
start to make a move tomorrow and move
over us which will cap off the monsoon
flow and then we'll just be hot and
drier with southwest breezes to help dry
us out 83 at mount charleston with
isolated thunderstorm chances today 109
out at lake mead and you know if you get
lightning and gusty winds out on the
open water can be very very dangerous
please watch the skies 108 for the
valley it's going to be a hot tuesday
for us but even hotter wednesday
thursday and friday look at that 110
not quite as hot for the weekend but
above normal and then next week slight
chances for storms return on monday